how's it guys my name is China welcome
back to the code review series a series
I want you guys send me your code and I
take a look at it so today we're
reviewing Pac-Man Italian Pac-Man uh
Pac-Man is not a game that I have seen
many people send in to be honest and I
was kind of in a retro mood today so I
figured you know let's take a look at
this so it's fully object oriented and I
would like to know what you think about
it if the usage of the objects is proper
and if it could somehow if it could be
somehow optimized uh and then here's the
link to the repository which will be
down below as well in case you guys want
to take a look at it all right
this is not what we want to see the
risks that I take for you guys okay so
my first piece of advice to you is never
ever ever ever zip your game into like a
little zip archive or whatever and push
it to your GitHub repository this is
supposed to be the code now this
actually reminds me of like the first
time I tried to use git I just knew that
GitHub was a website I wanted to publish
my code on GitHub so I assumed that it
was like publishing a YouTube video or
something like you just go to GitHub and
then you upload your files and drag them
in like Google drive or Dropbox or
something and you're done that's not
really how git works I think GitHub
added like a little like I'm pretty sure
you can you know if you own the
repository have Push access just upload
files arbitrarily it's probably what
this person has done add Advia upload
actually that's probably a good guess
but in general what you want to do is
like the simplest thing to do is
probably to get a UI like GitHub desktop
or fork and then well I don't want this
to be like a full on get tutorial is it
worth me doing like a just a classic git
tutorial maybe I don't know I'll leave
some resources like in description below
if you really don't know how to use git
or GitHub to get you started alright
anyway I suppose we should download this
guy right so here we have Pac-Man
um and these are the files that are
inside this archive that I just
downloaded now this obviously uses sdl
right I mean we can see it here as well
so what I might do is I might just set
this up through Visual Studio that's
probably another fun kind of tutorial
video that I should make at some point
just showing how to actually set up
something like this through Visual
Studio if it just does not have a visual
studio solution or project file let me
know if you want to see that in the
comments below alright so fast forward
to me setting everything up here we go
these are all of the files that we have
so there's only one CPP file and there's
a whole bunch of header files so we'll
talk about that in a minute but let's
just try and run this and here you go
Pac-Man ready let's
okay score kwsd Works our case work
looks like the behavior of the ghosts is
I mean I think it's correct let's go
quickly these guys this is quite a good
clone actually like it
it seems to have like all the features I
mean I haven't oh oops I forgot they're
not okay right so we've got one less
life now I haven't played Pac-Man in a
while though so like I can't
I don't really quite remember uh
everything
about it
but I think this seems legit I need to
get these two dots I need to actually
like
I guess I need to make sure that I can
um
actually like win this game
to actually test that so
I'm gonna actually try here
oh just made that all right
yep seems to work high score everything
this is pretty good this is pretty good
I'm actually kind of super I mean I'm
not surprised because I mean I don't
know you so I don't think it's a passage
to say I'm surprised but like I was not
expecting like this this is like a
full-on clone as far as I'm aware
so yeah I mean well done all right
anyway I'm actually really Keen to take
a look at this so first of all this
whole header situation is really the
first thing that I'm focusing on it's
not a good idea to put all of your
source code like this into headers now I
I I'm gonna just take a stab here oh
there's no header guards either I'm
gonna just take a stab here and say that
you probably came from another language
like C sharp or Java where you you just
kind of didn't have this whole concept
of like a header file and an
implementation file or a header file and
a source file or whatever most languages
don't have this and it's a little bit
archaic of C plus obviously to kind of
have this way of programming but it does
make sense and you just need to kind of
get used to the idea of how they work so
typically what you should do in your
header files is only contain
Declarations of classes what's
interesting is that it's like you've
almost got a hybrid approach here if we
take a look at this timer class what you
could have done is things like this
Constructor you actually could have just
gone ahead and implemented it here right
same with like the destructor and I'll
like start reset restart all of those
functions can actually be be just
created like that some people like to
write their classes like that because
obviously it's more reminiscent of other
languages like Java and c-sharp where
you do just you don't have like the
concept of a declaration and then and
then later a definition that actually
implements like the body of that
function this though luckily for you I
guess is really easy to kind of convert
over to being an implementation file
because all you have to do is basically
make another file here called timer.cpp
and then just grab like all of this
stuff all the way down to the bottom of
the file and leave this kind of intact
that's all you see in your header file
and then have this be in the kind of
implementation file in your CPP file and
then of course you have to include
timer.hp because otherwise this like
code that's sent to the compiler like
the compiler doesn't know what timer is
because if you don't have anything here
there's no Declaration of timer for it
to kind to be a valid class that can be
used to make sure this code actually
compiles correctly and like for example
the started variable exists because
that's obviously a variable inside this
class now um this doesn't work this is
also something that I remember I used to
struggle with when I was a wheelad whoa
what just happened it's July my hair ah
yeah so it's July um like this video
kind of really got away from me this
part where I talk about header files
actually made it to its own video I'll
have that linked up there so if you're
interested in like how to fix that
pedophile issue it's not in this video
it's in that video so go watch it uh
yeah so I'm basically gonna just resume
this code review and I feel like it's
been months so
um yeah header files obviously try and
not rely on them too much you should
pretty much always make kind of
implementation files CPP files um
especially if you have static data kind
of like this which this by the way
should probably be a Char array so you
could do something like this and I
wouldn't have this in a header file
because I promised I wouldn't really
speak too much about header files in
this video because I feel like that
other video that I released like months
ago kind of covered it but you really do
have to be careful when you write code
like this because I mean the thing is
it's a bit it's almost difficult to give
advice here because in this case you've
you've kind of made a Unity build right
that's kind of what you've done and what
what a Unity build is is basically when
you take all of your source code that
you have for your entire project and you
kind of just combine it all into like a
single file a single kind of C plus plus
file a single file that you then send to
the compiler as like a single
translation unit so that is effectively
kind of what we have here because these
are the only kind of source code files
in the project this makes up all of the
source code that makes up this game and
it's all being just included by the
preprocessor into this one single CPP
file that's sent to the compiler so in
that case when you see code like this
and all these globals the fact that
they're just declared like willy-nilly
right there's no like inline or static
here static you probably wouldn't use
here because that would mean every CPP
file would have a copy of this maybe you
would use inline to kind of make sure
that you didn't get any linking errors
and that would mean there's only one
copy of this function even though this
header file could get included
everywhere else but it's kind of like
you don't have that anymore because all
of this code just gets included once
into main.cbp and that's it so my point
being this is a very unique kind of
project this is a very interesting way
kind of of doing things again I wouldn't
do it like this for the reasons that I
outlined in that other video which is
linked up there but it's interesting
because a lot of things that like you
know if you just look at this header
file just like this is just a random
header file please look at my header
file hey is it good like this is weird
because like there's no header guide
yeah there's no pragma once or like an
if death but you shouldn't really use
pragma once is what you should use
there's no pragma once here this stuff
is just like arbitrarily declared like
without any kind of inline or static
kind of keywords and same with functions
they just have their definitions here
and again they don't have an inline or a
static keyword and the reason why any of
this matters is because if you take this
header file and try and include it into
multiple CPP files like two CPP files
none of this works so this literally
only works and that's why you don't need
a header guard like why would you need a
header guard if you're including this
this header file into one CPP file
header guards are for the sole purpose
of making sure that you do not include
that header file multiple times into a
single translation unit because that
will cause multiply defined symbols
effectively another unique thing about
these header files is that like there's
no includes yeah like it doesn't start
with like include this and that however
clearly we use things like entity type
or this ghost class that isn't even
defined here right because the first
line of code is literally a class
declaration so how does any of this work
if you look at this main dot CPP file
these are included in a very specific
order and the thing is if you actually
change the order of this like does it
compile at the moment so I hit Ctrl F7
just to compile this one file I mean
that's all we've got anyway if I just
like change ghost to be like here and I
hit Ctrl F7 look at this it doesn't
compile anymore right this is another
reason why this is bad because you have
to it's kind of like walking on thin ice
here like you have to make sure that
everything's included in the right order
because Blinky needs to know what ghost
is and the way C plus works is that it
kind of reads stuff kind of from top to
bottom so you need something declared up
the Top If code at the bottom references
it so like my point is this initialize
STL function has to be declared it has
to be declared somewhere up here it
can't be below its usage because the
compiler simply won't see that that's
obviously different in other languages
like c-sharp or Java but in C plus
that's how it works and everything that
is used by these like stuff from the C
plus standard library is up here here
and same with sdl all the sdl stuff
that's referenced by these files again
is included first so therefore when this
stuff gets all included into this one
file everything is there everything's
present everything works now there are
some advantages to this kind of um
architecture like build times
technically will be very fast however
they won't be potentially because you're
like if you're actually iterating
through this project it's almost almost
like you have some kind of pre-compiled
header file or just like again a Unity
build which people why do people make
Unity builds they make them to speed
things up although again a Unity build
is technically like CPP files are
usually combined into one however I say
it's there's no real difference right
between a CPP file or a header file here
because this is the entire
implementation anyway so anyway I'm
gonna stop talking I think about this
kind of weird architecture but I just
wanted to point that out really because
it's so unique like again out of
everything we've looked at on this code
review series I've never seen anything
like this and if someone kind of
stumbles upon it which a lot of you guys
I know are beginners like you might be
like how does this even work and I've
never seen simple Plus Code written like
this and I guess that's another reason
why I think personally sleepovers are so
cool other people might think that civil
laws is not cool because of this but
it's just really flexible like there are
so many ways you could write code
there's so many ways you could organize
your projects and so many different
conventions and styles you can use that
it almost ends up becoming like your
language and how you want to use it for
like that given project like the way we
use C plus plus and Hazel might be
drastically different to like I don't
know how like EA uses C plus plus and
Frostbite or like epic games uses it in
Unreal Engine right it almost feels like
a different language because of the kind
of flexibility and the tools almost that
you could build on top of the language
to almost form a meta language of how
you want to kind of write this project
and write this code now for those of you
who are kind of beginners and you do
want to learn more about this there's an
excellent freeway that you can actually
do that with the sponsor of today's
video brilliant.org brilliant is the
best way to learn computer science math
and data science interactively and
that's my favorite part about it it's an
online course platform with lots of high
quality courses on various stem topics
but they're super Visual and interactive
which helps not only with learning
computer science but also math I love
using brilliant for its math courses
because of that not to mention that the
lessons are very very bite-sized and
super helpful if you're busy which let's
be honest we probably all are and the
kind of range of content that they have
like if you're just starting out with
math for example they have this everyday
math course that's a really good gentle
introduction but then they go all the
way through to like linear algebra and
calculus which is like really useful for
the kind of work that I do and the best
thing about brilliant is that you can
get started for free they have a 30-day
free trial that you can use to check out
the entire platform just go to brian.org
channel link will be in the description
below and the first 200 people to sign
up will get 20 off an annual membership
if you do go on to like it huge thank
you to brilliant as always for
sponsoring this video so taking a look
at the main function we initialize STL
and then we make a bunch of kind of
Stack allocated uh classes which is good
right we all know we all should know by
now that we don't want to be allocating
kind of these classes on the Heap like
this because then we have to manually
delete them and also Heap memory tends
to be both slower to allocate and slower
to access so this is always preferred if
possible so we have the game we have the
game timer we have a vector called the
Mover this is actually kind of
interesting because again Pac-Man like I
haven't actually taken a look at a
Pac-Man game I think ever so I'm kind of
interested to see how you how you've
kind of programmed this I don't like
this weird inconsistent naming though so
like you have this called m game that's
like one convention then you have this
with a capital G that's like another
naming convention and then you have this
and like you know move up with just a
lowercase M another kind of third naming
convention be consistent right so if you
like this style then just do this right
there's no reason to kind of mix and
match all these things it looks weird
I'm also noticing like right for example
like this is a bunch of unsigned chars
right and you're pushing in right right
is clearly an enum try and avoid enums I
would use enum classes now in this case
though that is going to cause an error
here suddenly either way because you're
trying to push in and now why is this an
unsigned Char and not you know a
direction is like you know it seems like
this should be a direction uh and then
you would do Direction right now I guess
maybe it was an unsigned chart because
you were just using enums before and
they are effectively integers I mean
these are as well but the compiler
enforces certain kind of restrictions to
enumclasses versus enums that generally
helps you make less mistakes with them
that's why we prefer enumclasses but I
would definitely just use enumclasses
which again means that you can just
write code like this makes more sense
instead of just write like what is that
you know direction right okay it's it's
of type Direction what are the other
directions that I have available to me
oh look here they are right I like how
you have Direction nowhere by the way
that's funny which speaking of which I
mean this is minor but I would probably
put nowhere as the first one and kind of
give it the value zero you don't have to
explicitly give it that value it will by
default have the value zero as you can
kind of see over here because it's the
first thing but I almost do this
um just to to be more clear again not at
all telling you that you have to do this
I'm just telling you I do this but
nowhere kind of being a zero why does
that make more sense to me because if
you have a null Direction like if you
initialize Direction with something and
you're not you can't give it a value yet
instead of It kind of defaulting to zero
and being right which that previously
was the value zero it has the value
nowhere which kind of makes more sense
for a null direction if that makes sense
and obviously like you know in memory
this will just have the value zero which
also kind of is like null so hopefully
that sheds some light onto why I would
do it like that anyway let's get rid of
this stuff because otherwise the rest of
the code find compiles let's get rid of
this um but you you know you can still
actually put Direction in here it's just
I guess unsigned Char is what you chose
to do which you can see how this is like
it's already hopefully making the code
cleaner if you have Direction here and
direction right there okay game time
will start that's just that's just a
timer that we start then we play the
intro this is what so sound HTTP just
using mix which is the sdl mixer I'm
assuming
uh yep sure cool all right and then
while we haven't quit so we set quit to
false and then while not quit so while
we haven't quit this is just our main
game Loop we have iteration start again
with that lowercase I uh and then we do
sdl pull event and if the event type is
quit we quit now straight away over here
like if the event type is quit
um traditionally you would see more code
like this it's not technically a huge
deal but you would kind of see code like
this because if we have quit then
there's no point in US processing like
the rest of this while loop over here
and in fact there's no point in US
rendering anything either so you could
even have an if quit break or something
here now again you don't need to do any
of this but it's common to see that kind
of stuff because again there's no need
to process anything else and this is by
the way where technically speaking a
go-to would be good which you know I'm
not saying you should do this but you
can add a label called quit I'm probably
going to get canceled for this but you
you basically add a label here called
quit and then you say go to quit right
why is this good because that way we
don't have to break out of this Loop and
then also have to break out of this Loop
so when you're trying to kind of break
from two Loops the only way to do that
using kind of standard control flow in C
plus plus is to you know break here and
then do the thing that I did over here
which is basically if quit
then break again but this is just
annoying having this if statement so
therefore you can escape all of that by
just being like you know what let's just
get cut to the chase let's go to the
quit just so that we run this really
this one function and then we return and
that's kind of like the end of our
program but anyway most people will not
like that just because it kind of
violates normal control flow principles
in C plus plus and occasionally
sometimes it can actually cause errors
because you're kind of escaping stack
frames and Scopes and stuff without
potentially closing them so between you
and me I don't think it's that bad but
people have been canceled for Less now
as for the rest of this like we could
talk about this I'm always hesitant to
give kind of architecture advice to
projects like this because it's just a
simple Pac-Man game it doesn't
necessarily need to be over engineered
um you know just kind of code code style
wise I would definitely drop these onto
a different line
um but my kind of main point here is
that this probably just shouldn't be
here in the main function in general
when you look at a main Loop like I mean
just being completely serious here this
main loop I think might actually be
longer than Hazel's man loop right which
is crazy but the reason why is not
because this is more complex it's
because we kind of we almost treat this
main loop as like here is a summary of
what happens every frame like everything
stems from this it should almost be like
you know this is like the main Loop and
then what do we do we call this first
that second that third that fourth right
this is kind of like this is how the
game runs yeah these kind of four easy
steps and that's it why because it's
just a lot easier to read it's like okay
well the first thing we do is we pull
events we figure out if there's any kind
of events that have happened input
events quit events whatever then we do
like the rendering and like well the
game logic somewhere which surprisingly
doesn't even look like it's done here
like okay if game process Ah that's
behind an if statement that's
interesting we'll get to that in a
minute but we're kind of separated into
easy to digest blocks because like if I
if I really have to think about all the
possibilities uh you know what one might
argue that function calls are bad
because of perform moments which again
is absolutely a ridiculous claim in this
case because this is just a main Loop
right this isn't like this isn't a super
dense Loop this is really literally once
per frame but what you could have done
is like this kind of poly vents thing
yeah just make a function called poll
events uh and then go up here I would
make it static static void pole events
pop that over here now obviously like
the event that we're polling we'll grab
which that's up here so we can just move
that into here
um and then we have a few different
variables to kind of deal with which I
would probably make this into a class
like in in my opinion I feel like this
Loop should basically be in the game
class like you've got a lot of stuff
here I feel like the main Loop could
probably be moved to a function called
run and that way you would know like hey
has the game quit or not because I mean
I didn't think about this earlier
because I guess I didn't look at this
game class that looks very dense here
like it's got It's got the whole game in
it except for some reason it doesn't
have this mover and it doesn't have the
game timer it doesn't have the intro
sound or whatever like main functions
should be really as simple as possible
because they should just be like the
launching point and to further this
point like main functions can differ
like I think it's a good idea honestly
to just ask yourself like why why do
main functions have to be simple like
why do why do people do that and again
for a game like this it might not matter
too much but one example I can think of
off the top of my head is that the entry
point might actually change so like if
I'm making a Windows application I would
probably use win main which is just a
different entry point if I'm making like
I don't know an Android app this becomes
an Android app or something the entry
point for that again is going to be
different so my point is it's not always
going to be literally this function and
because of that if you have everything
within this function you're going to
have to move it out eventually or you're
going to have to like what duplicate
this code like you wouldn't want to do
that which is why if we take a look at a
Hazel as an example like we have like
this main function this is the entry
point all we have this win main function
that's the windows entry point but what
do they do they call Hazel main which is
up here here that has the main kind of
app Loop which is different from the
game Loop this effectively encompasses
the entire life cycle of the actual
application and there are some reasons
for that such as maybe you want to
trigger a restart of the whole program
and so you would kind of shut everything
down and re-initialize it but anyway the
point is and then we create the
application then we run the application
when that's done we shut it down but the
point is you can see that that kind of
gets delegated out into the application
class which that kind of encompasses
what a Hazel application actually is so
that's definitely something I would just
adopt for any project really and one of
the benefits there is you do actually
get a class that can contain member
variables and the benefit of that is you
don't have to have free floating
functions and then either pass stuff
around or keep them in global kind of
variable space or Global symbol kind of
scope instead you can just have them as
class members and everything will work
out great um all right let's kind of
move on here so we then run this okay so
yeah then we do render it clear sure so
we clear that it's a little bit weird to
me that like the rendering so the
rendering only seems to happen if this
returns true because that's where you
allegedly draw the game but but then
you're also clearing every frame so what
tells me is that if this function
returns false you've cleared the screen
but you don't render anything which is a
bit weird like I would think it would
make more sense to just retain the same
game board you know and not kind of
clear anything in which case I would
probably expect this to be here just
logically but um it's up here which is
weird maybe this always returns true
let's take a look at what this process
function does again kind of that's
annoying that it's in a header file
um return true okay so we do return
false oh okay okay interesting so if the
lives if that animation ended lives are
greater than zero
on the board
uh
and then if the but but if it is dead
animation ended we return false
so maybe for like a few frames the
return Falls potentially because that
that happens up here as well if the map
animation time so maybe that that maybe
that is deliberate like you just want to
clear the game board sometimes and not
render anything for a few frames while
you reset everything sure I would say
that it's not like this isn't a very
clear way of doing that oh here we go
return false when should render the last
animation frame it's bad looking so I
don't want to render it
huh the last animation frame is bad
looking
that's interesting okay the alignment
here looks super bad looking as well
like what is I don't know what's going
on with this alignment and also all of
these nested if statements that's also a
little bit weird um yeah like this is
also something something really really
really classic that I see a lot and that
is just like you have very very deep
logic you have like let's just say we
have 20 different things that could
happen when we process the game and
obviously they are predicated on a bunch
of conditions like for example is this
if statement true in which case we saw
the game or is it not is the player
alive or is the level completed or is
the map animation timer started or is it
do we have lives remaining like is there
are we playing the death animation
there's so many different conditions
here and what that results in I guess is
what people would call Spaghetti code
right like this is just a bit annoying
and I feel like I always hear people
referencing terraria's source code
because it's just a bunch of nested if
statements and the thing is there's
nothing like really that wrong with that
though in terms of the computer and its
ability to process this data it's really
one of those things that just affects
the developer most of all because this
just sucks like this just sucks to deal
with right if I look at this and I'm
like oh yeah we despawn fruit okay in
what case do we despawn fruit like when
does this happen Okay so the dead
animation uh has to have ended the lives
has to be above zero uh we have to be in
the else block of I guess Pac-Man is a
lot oh so we're dead right so if we're
dead but we still do have more than one
life yeah so we're not completely game
over but we did just die this life uh
and also I guess game time and get Texas
lesson start text so we're not in the
starting phase of the game I guess we're
in the actual main gameplay kind of part
of it okay so in that case that's when
we do this you know what I mean like
this just it's just really really
difficult and again this is where a
state machine comes in and I've
mentioned State machines before and I
think you guys wanted me to make a video
specifically be demonstrating how I
would reorganize this into a state
machine so I think honestly I'm going to
end this code review here and my next
video probably not my next video but a
video in the future I'm going to take
this game because I actually kind of
like this game there's a lot we can do
here to fix it but also it's just a
really well done Pac-Man clone like it's
just good yeah I'm gonna take ownership
of this I want to steals these and I
want to make this beautiful that's going
to be my little project it's going to be
a perfect little holiday project because
I'm going away for a break soon and
we're going to talk about how we can
kind of take this convert it into a
state machine probably reorganize this
stuff to not be a Unity build I would
like to take a look at Marta's code but
like I don't know these code reviews
always inflate to being very very long
so we will definitely take a look at
that but I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button let me know what you
want to see kind of dissected in this if
there's anything you saw there that
you'd like more detail on and let me
know if you're excited about this kind
of state machine idea I just feel like
doing something actually practical and
seeing like a before and after might
make more sense than just my words so I
think that's what I'm going to do thank
you guys for watching again don't forget
to check out brilliant.org the channel
and I will see you next time goodbye